Аби дістатися на роботу,
журналіст Deutsche Welle Ескандер Абаді щоденно долає маршрут з Кельна до Бонна.
Здавалося б, нічого особливого,
але чоловік - незрячий.
Утім, це не заважає йому самотужки добиратися спершу трамваєм,
потім метро
і ще шмат дороги пішки.
Німецькі вулиці та пішохідні зони здебільшого безбар’єрні
та пристосовані для комфортного пересування,
зокрема, і людей з вадами зору.
На тротуарах є біла смужка з нерівною поверхнею.
Коли незряча людина торкається її,
вона розуміє: тут перехрестя.
Загалом на вулицях німецьких міст
частіше помічаєш людей з обмеженими можливостями,
ніж в Україні.
Не тому, що їх тут більше, а тому, що міська інфрастуктура
набагато краще пристосована до їхніх потреб
і уможливлює їхнє вільне пересування.
Німці ретельно підходять до питання інклюзії
і намагаються забезпечити людей з інвалідністю тими ж можливостями,
які мають здорові люди.
Якщо люди з інвалідністю хочуть піти до театру або в кіно чи просто зустрітися,
то вони повинні мати таку можливість.
Приміром, якщо вони не користуються автомобілем, то повинні мати можливість
дістатися свого місця призначення громадським транспортом.
Саме це означає для нас інклюзію у суспільне життя.
Міський транспорт враховує потреби людей з інвалідністю, літніх людей з ходунками,
людей з вадами слуху та зору.
Загалом зупинки громадського транспорту пристосовані
для пересування на інвалідних візках.
Автобус зупиняється, водій опускає пандус –
і людина на візку без перешкод заїжджає всередину.
Щоб спуститися у метро люди з обмеженими можливостями
можуть використовувати
спеціальні ліфти чи траволатори.
У трамваях, автобусах чи вагонах метро,
окрім оголошення зупинок, є монітори з маршрутом руху транспорту та кнопки "Стоп",
розташовані на рівні інвалідного візка.
Комунальні служби міста Бонна працюють
у тісній співпраці з громадськими організаціями,
які представляють права інвалідів,
і, консультуючись з ними, поліпшують доступність транспорту.
Ми завжди разом обговорюємо нові проекти або нові об'єкти,
які підлягають відновленню.
Таким чином, ми залучені у всі процеси,
пов'язані з доступністю.
Ми звертаємося до спілки  інвалідів, щоб вони надали нам людину на інвалідному візку,
яка би проїхалася новим автобусом і пояснила,
що ми можемо поліпшити, щоб зробити проїзд
максимально комфортним.
Переважна більшість зупинок відповідає
потребам людей з обмеженими можливостями.
У міських бюджетах регулярно закладаються гроші
на модернізацію старих зупинок,
де ще є бар’єри, щоб люди на візках ставали ще мобільнішими.
Для мене залишається проблемою безперешкодно дістатися до роботи,
тому що зупинка, де я маю виходити з трамваю,
не є безбар’єрною.
Мені доводиться їхати автобусом до іншої зупинки,
яка пристосована для інвалідних візків.
Спілка інвалідів Бонна
займається скаргами людей з інвалідністю
і сповіщає комунальні служби про їхні потреби.
Вони також надають інформацію про безбар’єрне пересування містом
через веб-додаток "Bonn inklusiv".
За допомогою цієї програми люди з особливими потребами
можуть перевірити потрібний їм маршрут
та як найзручніше дістатися місця призначення на візку.
У нас є відділ скарг,
куди люди з обмеженими можливостями звертаються з проблемами,
з якими вони стикаються у своєму повсякденному житті.
Вони надсилають нам електронні листи,
дзвонять або приходять сюди особисто.
Музеї, кафе, кінотеатри та інші громадські місця у Німеччині
також намагаються враховувати потреби людей з інвалідністю.
Для них передбачені широкі ліфти
і пристосовані до їхніх потреб вбиральні.
А в музеях, наприклад, за потреби можна отримати для пересування інвалідні візки.
Ескандер Абаді переконаний,
що всі ці зручності у міському транспорті,
пішохідних зонах та громадських місцях
потрібні не тільки людям з обмеженими можливостями,
але й батькам з дитячими візочками,
подорожувальникам з важкими валізами,
пацієнтам, що тимчасово змушені користуватися милицями.
Тож, від цього виграє все суспільство.